self-described white supremacist Daniel
ROA was just so angry when he saw a
black man and a white woman kissing in
Olympia Washington that he stabbed the
interracial couple the 32 year old row
walked up to the couple and without
warning yelled a racial slur and lunged
with his knife according to police the
blade Gray's the woman and went into the
man's hip according to a statement from
the Olympia police after the attack and
this is the most amazing part ro ran off
as stunned onlookers dialed 911 and the
47 year old male who had been stabbed
not realizing how badly he was injured
actually chased down the white
supremacist tripped him up and held him
on the ground a rather he hit his head
on the ground and was knocked
unconscious until police showed up it's
number one aside from the hate crime
nature and just horrific nature of
thinking that there's something wrong
with people of different races being in
a relationship it's incredible that
after being stabbed you actually chased
down the stabber trip him and then the
guys knocked unconscious and just uh it
lays there until police show up yeah
that's great and this is another one of
those stories white supremacists they
they pretend they're tough but they're
really not is that what you think yeah
and a lot of I mean the vast majority of
them hide behind screens in and post
comments on YouTube like the ones you
see right down here um and yeah I find
that that tends to be the case police
said that when they showed up Rowe was
unconscious that he had tattoos that
said skinhead white power and hooligan
and one tattoo showed a confederate flag
he was arrested booked into Thurston
County Jail on two charges of
first-degree assault impossible
malicious harassment and uh I I like how
police say this has all of the hallmarks
of a hate crime what gave it away the
racial slur precipitated by a stabbing
by a guy with all sorts of white
supremacist tattoos on his body uh how
do you get to a place in your life Jason
where you see a couple kissing and think
their skin is a different color so I
should stab
I think it's many many false layers of
logic piled on top of a you know very
simple and mystic brain that's to me
that's all it could be really but
parenting has to be somewhat responsible
right i mean it dude the reason i say
that is if at no point in your childhood
do you start getting these ideas from
parents it would be harder to just be
completely invaded with these ideas in
the so-called outside world although it
can happen i guess there's a lot of
weird youtube videos around people can
be radicalized by but these I there's
nothing natural about this type of
racism it has to be learned from
somewhere doesn't it well I mean I come
from a very racist South Boston Irish
kinda background and you know maybe
sometimes Apple falls from the tree no
Apple but sometimes in orange and
sometimes you know you go the opposite
of you know what you've been taught
because you actually know it's wrong
yeah I mean there's probably something
to that we knew we do know some people
and we've interviewed former actually
like for example Scott Shepherd former
KKK guy yep who actually had sort of an
awakening because he was completely
surrounded by that type of thing
absolutely crazy uh it makes absolutely
no sense to me that anyone would see two
people kissing and and say I need to get
involved even though the situation
affects me in absolutely no way although
they would probably say no they are
being affected by it because this is
such a perversion of how the races
should be divided in society or
something like that that's yet their
logic maybe they think they're
protecting white people or up who knows
I'm guessing that the white woman is a
race traitor of some kind yeah yeah if
you were to ask this guy I'm sure that
she deserved to be stabbed as well